edition of hannity officials continue
facing backlash from small business
owners
as they impose more draconian
coronavirus restrictions
last night dirty jobs host mike rowe
joined hannity to discuss the new
measures take a look
it's been a slow burn for me to be
honest but i have come to the point
where you know candace mentioned
irredeemable
and deplorable there's a new word for 40
million people in this country
non-essential and it's crazy
we have deemed a giant hunk
of our people essentially one click away
from
unimportant or worthless what happens to
an economy when you call
men like those non-essential people
meanwhile in california there are
reports of growing democratic support
for a recall of california governor
gavin newsom
a group seeking to oust newsome already
has over 800
000 signatures over halfway to the 1.5
million they need
by mid-march to get the recall effort on
the ballot
and on the other coast in new york in
response to governor cuomo
closing indoor dining one new york city
restaurant owner
rocco sacramone dined outdoors in a snow
storm watch this
so we'll as you can see we're having
outdoor dinner
only four weeks so i hope we're not
breaking the rule
the pizza and the snow plate here looks
nice we're gonna have a little piece of
mozzarella
guys mozzarella and the snow plate also
here
so this is how we're going to be doing
now outdoor dinner
or outdoor lunch in new york city from
today on
joining us now with more is the new york
city restaurant owner you just saw
rocco sacramone i hope i pronounced your
last name right
and fox news contributor emily campagno
i know i pronounced her name right
rocco thanks for joining us here explain
to people at home
what you're going through in your
restaurant
hi thanks for having me on jason um well
it's really tough times right now for
the restaurant
any restaurant uh in the city uh the
the the motive of the of the video is
not to mock anyone but it was just to
show how it's almost impossible to have
dinner outside in new york city in the
month of december
in the middle of a snow storm or rather
it's when the temperatures are
uh in the 20s and 30s uh
tents do not work heaters do not work
none of the stuff work and it's
impossible to
to make up a patron um
to give him a full satisfaction of full
experience of the of a dining experience
at the restaurant
so rocco if you had an opportunity to
talk to governor
cuomo or to mayor de blasio for that
matter what would you tell them
well uh we we should follow the science
i
totally agree i'm not a doctor i'm not a
scientist but we should
before we make any any decision uh
to shut something down
let's let's not just shut down because
we want to shut down
you know let's think about it first i
mean
this is the month of december okay we
have christmases here
we my restaurant went from 35 to 40
employees we went to four or five maybe
you know so let's just
not to hurry up things and just do it
for the because we need to shut down
now and emily you know rocco makes a
good point because
there isn't science back that i'm aware
of that supports this idea so how do you
think the courts are going to look at
this your background is in the law
well we've seen one case thus far where
a judge did rule in the california
restaurant association's favor and said
you're right the science at this point
hasn't differentiated
between indoor and outdoor dining and
the transmissions thus far
but after that the governor issued
another edict
banning outdoor and indoor dining and
then that's what we've heard sort of a
lot of headlines
about the strip club ruling well just a
couple hours ago
the ruling that enabled the strip clubs
to remain open and applied to all of san
diego county restaurants
now that was overturned at the appellate
level and keep in mind too
to rocco's point a lot of restaurant
owners even with the ruling said
well we don't want to open because we
can't put that resources into it
if we know that we might get shut down
really soon afterward
so it's not that this green light has
any type of dependability whatsoever
because they're used to the fact that
it's
green light red light throughout this
whole thing with absolutely no science
to back it up so there's no way
of predictability with this at all let
alone bringing employees back
so rocco what are you going to do what
do you tell those employees and what do
you tell the people that love going to
your restaurant
well i mean i i feel really bad for my
you know for my employees i mean
we have people that have been working at
the restaurant for 10 years 15 years 20
years how do you tell how do you let
someone go
after all this time you know i mean we
they impose so many rules and
regulations on us right
we have we put it we also had a
filtration system a puridyne
that it's supposedly it's supposedly
clear the air
against stars but at the then we do all
this work and then we get shut down
again
so i'll give you an example what
happened today today we have no internet
we have no phone lines we have nothing
so how are we going to deliver today for
example how do we
there's no solution to this problem i
mean we just keep on dragging the dragon
and dragging it
emily i've only rocco your food looks
great and i
i wish you the best emily i've got about
15 seconds here
can these people like rocco prevail
in the courts i hope so
as an attorney and just as an american
my heart goes out to you rocco your food
looks delicious and i do hope that we
will see
um some type of comfort for all of you i
i got to tell you
rocco you represent a lot of people from
coast to coast because
business is hard enough it's hard enough
to be an employee and have to rely on
tips and those types of things
but god bless you because you make a
good product and it is essential
so thank you so much for that